uh all right so this new album is coming
out uh well by the time you're watching
this it'll be out
um new money new money september 23rd
about 16 songs off fire 16 records would
you and vezo do a collab tape
i don't know it might happen you never
know i feel like with that smile it's
already happening you never know
is it already happening i don't know
that would make sense you guys are both
on the same label both from the same
city
both fire
it can't happen how many songs in the uh
or just in the cut do you all have
together that are that aren't out
i ain't got that man not that many no no
have you been able to uh you know he's
somebody who kind of inspires me because
uh
you know when he got out of jail man he
just really got to it and uh
he ain't stopped yet yeah and and you
know even though he had that motown
situation that kind of ended up not
working out
he
when he left motown he really turned up
and just the
you know his he's just expanding in the
movies and he's got his potato chips and
there he got his baby the vapes
we went to the liquor store out there
and he had vapes and chips in that
[ __ ]
and the chips are fire for sure have you
had the chips
super good i'll be under attacking them
all the time buying boxes yeah shots and
i ain't buying them off like because
that's my god buy them because they're
good though of course they're amazing
yeah